قصص مؤثره خلفها زلزال تركيا وسوريا فهذه
المراه المسنه تشكو ماساتها وتامل ربما في
العثور على ناجين من ذويها ومثلها اخرون
فقدوا الابناء والاحباء
فقط شهداء وطالعون بس بنت وحده من تحت
الانقاض
المشهد في سوريا المنقسمه مناطقها
المنكوبه بين سيطره النظام والمعارضه اصبح
الحديث فيها عن تلاشي امل العثور عنا جينا
جدد خاصه بعد اعلان المرصد السوري لحقوق
الانسان ان عدد المفقودين في سوريا يقدر
باكثر من 2000 شخص اغلبهم في جنديرس وقرى
مختلفه لم تصلها اصلا فرق الانقاذ
المرصد اضاف ايضا ان ما يجري حاليا في
المناطق المنكوبه هو رفع الانقاض وتحديد
مراكز لاواء الناجين مع توفير مساعدات
امميه ودوليه بدات تصل تباعا الى سوريا
في المقابل المشهد في تركيا مختلف بعض
الشيء وان كان متحركا في مدينه من اصل 10
ضربها الزلزال هما هاتاي وقهرمان مرعش
ومع استمرار عمليات البحث عن ناجينا جدد
في تركيا برزت قضيه المفقودين
لتمثل هاجسا مقلقا للسلطات وخوفا حقيقيا
لذوي المفقودين وتقول فرق الانقاذ ومنظمات
انسانيه ان كل من بقي تحت ركامي زلزال
تركيا وسوريا يعتبر في عداد الموتى رغم
دخول عمليات البحث عن ناجين يومها العاشر